bonsoir dr weiss alors beaucoup de
choses ce soir anosy rondement avec le
vaccin
le vaccin a des 5 n cove basé sur une
technologie canadienne a été développé
par l'entreprise chinoise là alors
est-ce qu'on doit est-ce qu'on doit être
content ce qu'il ya quelque chose de
bien dans cette nouvelle lattès et le
canada est impliqué là dedans je suis
extrêmement prudent avec ce genre
d'annoncés
il faut toujours voir qu'est-ce qui veut
être annoncé par quelle compagnie et
pourquoi avant de pouvoir dire qu'un
vaccin est efficace et sécuritaire il
faudrait avoir des données beaucoup plus
poussée c'est très rare que des
médicaments façon générale dans un
processus normal
lorsqu'ils sont pas au tout début de
leur développement on annonce qui sont
déjà très prometteur donc avant d'aller
la vente ce genre de nouvelles like vous
toujours prendre ça avec des pincettes
et s'assurer qu'il y ait beaucoup plus
de données disponibles et beaucoup plus
disponible parfait avant de commencer à
donner trop d'espoir aux gens parce
qu'il ya plus d'une centaine de vaccins
actuellement développement très bien
test de dépistage sérologique ça par
contre c'est très concret pas ça arrive
ici
santé canada a donné l'autorisation
premier test de dépistage sérologique à
laval il ya des gens qui l'ont fait nos
collègues l'a fait d'ailleurs ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour à en connaître
davantage sur la le taux d'infection des
gens alors tout à fait c'est pas un test
diagnostique c'est un test qui va nous
permettre de connaître la dynamique de
l'épidémiologie c'est à dire quelle est
la proportion de patients qui ont été
infectés par le virus
on pourra faire des études selon les
groupes d'âge selon les emplois selon
les villes selon les endroits à
l'intérieur des villes
donc ça va nous permettre aussi de
suivre dans le temps ce n'est pas une
panacée il ya des mythes hôtel
sérologique
mais c'est une situation qui est
absolument nécessaire d'avoir la plupart
des pays ont déjà commencé des tests
sérologiques nous on s'est occupés en
cette équipe et dans mon hôpital pour
pouvoir faire de la sérologie de cela ça
va pouvoir être disponible rapidement
surtout qu'il ya un test maintenant qui
vient d'être approuvée au canada
et donc ce test là il va falloir
l'utiliser pourquoi c'est important
d'être rapidement sur nos
on va dire on va appeler ça sur le bloc
de départ parce qu'il va y avoir une
compétition mondiale comme mais pour les
masquer il ya eu pour les tests
diagnostiques et si on n'est pas capable
de se positionner rapidement pour avoir
livré à des machines etc
eh ben on va être encore pris à essayer
de compétitionner avec tout le monde et
c'est pour ça que quand ça va être
disponible rapidement et on espère en
tout cas nous rapidement qu'on va
pouvoir offrir ce test là à la
population et aussi en collaboration
avec les gens de la santé publique parce
que tout ça doit être fait sous un
travail global ou pouvoir ou déterminer
quels groupes de population au québec
doit être ciblée en priorité qui on doit
tester pourquoi les travailleurs de la
santé etc
alors il va falloir aussi se positionner
dans ce domaine là bon mais on avance
là-dessus la situation dr weill dans les
hôpitaux de la grande région de montréal
qui sont les plus sollicités
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dira t
elle a beaucoup changé sur certains
aspects donc le nombre
d'hospitalisations a stagné
le bon côté c'est qu'on n'a pas plus de
patients en soins intensifs
malheureusement ce qu'on n'est pas
capable de faire on n'a pas de
ressources intermédiaires mise en place
encore qui vont pouvoir ressortir les
patients âgés
ils font actuellement dans les hôpitaux
qui n'ont plus vraiment besoin de soins
et but mais qui bloque délié qu'on n'est
pas capable d'envoyer vers le réseau de
la santé qui devrait comme une espèce de
fluide avec des niveaux
je vous dirais différentes interventions
donc ces gens là ont encore besoin de
soins médicaux mais pas de soins
médicaux dans les hôpitaux de soins
aigus ou là les lits sont bloqués dont
on peut pas faire de chirurgie on veut
pour repérer des cancers on peut pas
traiter des gens ont des problèmes
cardiovasculaires dont il ya tout cet
aspect là qu'on va devoir reprend et on
n'est pas capable de sortir les patients
vous voyez pourrait commencer à avoir un
flot plus intense malgré le fait qu on
est loin des grands espaces dans
l'ancien hôpital l'hôtel-dieu la place
belle à laval mais il manque de
personnel mais c'est pas l'espace qui
manque c'est le personnel pour
accueillir ces gens c'est un ensemble de
facteurs essais il va falloir trouver
des ressources
organiser des structures pour qu'on
puisse sortir ces patients-là qui
hier beaucoup mieux à l'extérieur des
hôpitaux de soins aigus où il ya
d'autres risques pour ces patients là
entre autres les infections nosocomiales
etc
et c'est pas le plat c'est pas la place
idéale pour traiter ce genre de patients
là dans leurs étapes de leur évolution
ne s'est pas réglé c'est ce qu'on entend
c'est pas réglé questions du public dr
weiss pouvez-vous vous nous donner de
l'information au sujet on vient au
fameux masque de comment porter et
entretenir les différents types de
masques bon écoutez le masque jaune et 1
devant moi qu'est ce qu'on appelle un
masque de procédure c'est un masque
simple ces masses que là bas vous avez
ici une espèce de bandelettes de métal
donc ce qui est important c'est de
couvrir son nez out au dessous du menton
dont vous devriez comme ça à aller
jusqu'en bas du menton c'est très
important de couvrir formés parce que
très souvent on voit des gens portaient
le masque de cette façon là avec donc le
nez qui est visible ou quoi que ce soit
et c'est pas la façon de faire c'est
masculin est aussi c'est important de
bien les enlever idéalement lorsque vous
arrivez la maison si vous les avez porté
dans les transports en commun etc
faites attention quand vous touchez
votre face parce que le plus important
c'est de ne pas se contaminer en
enlevant le matin je m'explique vous
êtes dans le métro vous portez un masque
vous arrivez chez vous vous les enlevez
le mas
lavez vous les mains avant c'est
important de bien se laver les mains
parce que si vous avez touché des
surfaces où vous avez du virus à ce
moment là il faut que ce virus là vous
soyez capable d'enlever et donc après
vous irez enlever votre masque si vous
avez un masque on appelle on va dire
artisanale l'a donc ce genre de masque
là que vous pouvez à la limite la baie
et quand vous voyez le masisi à un
espèce de petite poche à l'intérieur où
vous pouvez rajouter quelque chose va
être il va servir de filtre annonce
appel par exemple un filtre à café ça
puait donc vous pourriez faire ce genre
de choses là vous allez avoir une
protection supplémentaire et ses masters
à l'avantagé sont lavables et donc vous
pouvez les réutiliser autant de fois que
vous voulez et ça apporte une certaine
protection
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre à
l'intérieur c'est n'importe quoi qui
pourrait être présent un filtre à café
et on a su gérer beaucoup de choses puis
toutes les idées sont bonnes ben
justement après avoir utilisé mon masque
vous demandons si je le place en
confinement et je ne le réutilise pas
pendant trois jours par exemple je leur
porte et ensuite autrement dit 'tiens
cil à cil le virus est là ce qui ne sera
pas mort tout seul
oui personnellement quel type de masse
parce que si c'est un masque en tissu
vous aviez de laver l affaire est réglée
à ce moment là vous aurez pas vous
casser trop la tête 6 et des masques
quant au pont utilisent des masses de
procédure ces masques là vous pouvez les
porter tant et aussi longtemps qu'ils ne
sont pas invités mouillé parce que là
ils perdent de leur efficacité
ou bien sûr déchirer alors à partir du
moment où vous l'enlevez correctement et
que vous leur mettez par la suite même
durant la journée c'est correct mais là
encore le plus importante c'est au
moment d'enlever votre masque c'est le
moment le plus dangereux
laver les mains et de passions d'avril
main et d'enlever son masque de façon en
bloc donc essayé d'enlever le masque
sans trop se toucher les visages en
essayant de prendre par les oreilles
puis sortir le masque en bloc et le
déposer est-ce qu'on peut mettre les
masques ou micro-ondes
ça revient ça se fait quarante jours que
ça revient pour les désinfecter à la
réponse est non mais t'es fait n'étaient
pas des masses micro très bien et on
finit par une digue à elle abigaël dix
ans quand nous jouerons la corde à
danser
est-ce que nous pouvons la partager ça
la désinfecter c'est pas celle là c'est
la dernière question numéro 4 alors oui
maintenant savourer pour répondre à vie
gay non parce que là le contact des
mains peut évidemment contaminer la
corde alors si je la ferais tu as mon
ami et mon amie elle est potentiellement
infectées puis apprend la corde à ce
moment là le danger que ont pu y serez
infectés de façon continue
alors pas de cordes à danser d'ailleurs
s'il fallait voir on s'adapte quand même
presque à tout docteur va être les cours
d'école ou les récréations les genres et
les jeunes restaient sur des petits
points rouges et bougeait sur place
quand même extraordinaire capacité
d'adaptation de l'humain tout à fait il
faut pas sous-estimer les enfants vous
savez on a essayé on a beaucoup dit ah
ils seront pas capables ils seront pas
capables vous voyez les écoles qui
commencent à rouvrir
dans beaucoup de pays en europe les
enfants sont capables de vraiment
s'adapter rapidement
merci dr weiss à très bientôt remercie
toujours apprécié on voit le plaisir à
voir